wow january's hopping you see all those
movies coming out
exactly but that affords opportunity to
talk about other things and first i do
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by dr
squatch dr swatch is changing the way
men approach hygiene by providing
natural healthy products that make you
feel great and smell like a champion
their soap doesn't have any of those
weird harmful chemicals that other big
soap companies use seriously some soap
companies is like you trying to clean me
or turn me into a three-eyed fish and
release me into springfield i still use
dr squatch to this day i've used dr
squatch ever since they first sponsored
that first video all that time ago
haven't used another shower soap since
right now my shower is bay rum it's
smooth
yet spicy so click the link below and
use my promo code dsq john's to get
yourself 20 off your purchase of 20 or
more and thank you once again to dr
squatch for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it and now it's a time long
past time it's overdue to talk about
cobra kai season four but i gotta tell
you this in all fairness thomas ian
griffith the one who plays terry silver
in karate kid three and cobra kai found
out that he is
actually younger than ralph macchio who
plays daniel larusso i learned that
information then now waking up from a
catatonic state um it's time to do this
it's late now is that really what
happened well you know it's going to be
my version of events
till the grave it's younger than ralph
my [ __ ] hell it's just weird you know
you look at karate kid threes like yeah
john chris and i we fought in vietnam
also i'm younger than the guy playing
the fresh out of high school students
all right cobra kai season four is the
newest season of cobra kai also spoiler
warning gonna talk spoilers not gonna be
a play-by-play just some things i liked
about the season but going to talk about
pretty much you know all of it in terms
of the end don't spoil the warning in
cobra guys it's not like
it's not like eric draven from the crows
shows up it's like hey i'm here to join
eagle fang it's nothing like that
happens but you know in case you're
concerned you've been born so where
cobra kai left off last time as the
cobra kai kids broke into daniel russo's
place and they got into a big old brawl
john crease was like we'll settle this
at the tournament which to be fair
that's the thing i like about cobra kai
a show that should be getting old right
about now for me i should be just kind
of tired of it but i'm not they do a
good job at keeping you on your toes
throwing some curve balls and at the
very least listening to the online
chatter i mean the show runners of cobra
kai have to have their finger on the
pulse of the social media chatter more
than any show i've ever seen because
after cobra kai's season 3 a lot of
people were like
why didn't they just call the cops
what's up with this settled distance
tournament thing why no so in cobra kai
season 4 they addressed that i guess sam
really didn't want to draw it out so
they were like okay we won't call the
cops i mean sounds like a [ __ ]
excuse
but it shows me that the showrunners are
listening to feedback so in a world
where johnny lawrence and his eagle fang
dojo have teamed up with daniel larusso
and the miyagi doe dojo to take on the
greater enemy which is now cobra kai run
by john crease john crease gets terry
silver back into the mix
he's just like hanging out at vegan
brunches and john crease is like
we can't have that he looks happy ish i
mean as happy as a really wealthy guy
eating vegan brunch can be that's what i
love about john crease john crease he's
a virus he's a cancer he's a blight on
not only karate
the lives of the people around him so he
gets terry silver back i thought terry
silver was an awesome and amazing
addition to cobra kai so the dynamic of
terry silver and john crease was a
little different than i thought it was
in karate kid 3. like in the cobra kai
villainous hierarchy i always saw terry
silver as above john crease like john
crease was the villain then in the
sequel you find out that there's
actually a villain above that villain
that villain had a boss and i saw terry
silver as that boss but i went back and
looked at karate kid 3 with new eyes
because i hadn't seen the movie in years
and had it wrong terry silver is
definitely john creese's soldier not the
other way around like i thought you want
to see some more i want to see a lot
more bring them back and john crees
still has that hold over terry silver to
this day and i love that season four
hammered home that complexity for terry
silver's character now there are some
things you see coming
50 million miles away at least one
season away where it's like oh johnny
lawrence and daniel larusso they're
working together no one thought that was
gonna work out extremely well you know
you know they're gonna clash and they do
but the show has fun with it however
ridiculous the show can be
it makes up for it by having fun with
the premise it doesn't try to hide it
doesn't try to run from it it's like
yeah but we'll have fun we'll entertain
the [ __ ] out of the audience i love that
daniel trains johnny in the ways of
miyagido and johnny's like all right now
you're going to learn my way of karate
it's it's hilarious his monologue about
how everything in the world is trying to
make you soft and one of the things he
throws out there is like automatic
transmission i was like preach but i
totaled that camaro
rest its soul some things that stand out
in season four as great moves they made
like robbie they actually use him
at the very least he becomes his own
character he does his own thing he's
like nope
i'm with cobra kai now in fact i'm gonna
train cobra kai students in the way of
miyagido so in the tournament they know
how to counter and fight miyagi but in
terms of his characters character has
conviction this season that's what i
liked about it and that's with the new
character kenny payne which at first i
was like we've seen this a hundred times
before it's kind of the karate kid cobra
kai storyline you know oh the new kid
who gets bullied he learns martial arts
he learns karate we get it but again
it's not as cliche as it could have been
there are about three or four angles in
this one story arc that ties between
different characters that makes it feel
like something that needed to happen
robbie mentors this kid which gives him
that teacher-student relationship which
brings him closer to understanding a
father-son relationship and how mistakes
are made in those scenarios also daniel
larusso's son
remember his son his son that never
stood out or did anything just kind of
had his head in video games yeah they
actually use him in this season too they
use him again as the bully that you
wouldn't expect to be the bully and they
kind of flipped the script on that which
they kind of did in terms of bullies in
the first season of cobra kai but daniel
larusso's son is bullying this kenny
payne kid which then leads to robbie
teaching this kenny payne kid so there's
this trifecta going on where i liked how
it was woven together and i like how it
led to robbie being like i'm tired of
blaming you dead
hug and we'll see where next season goes
i mean grant it's a little fast i
imagine in real life there'll be
years upon years of therapy before it
comes to that phase but we don't have
that many years cobra kai in the course
of all four of its seasons thus far has
taken place in the course of about a
year for the characters that's why like
when it gets all high school drama-ish
and like uh miguel kister but also i
gotta remember for the characters it
hasn't been four years it's not like oh
four years dude how long you gonna hold
on to that it's one year or so thus far
hawk turns good we're we kind of saw
that in the last season but he was still
hocked but now robbie and the cobra
kai's held him down and shaved his
mohawk off so he lost his hawk identity
he's now eli moskowitz again he has to
deal with that which again great lesson
and he's still a badass in the
tournament he completely kicks ass but
the tournament has more logistics now
it's not just like tournament style
whittles down to two people and then the
winner that's it no there's like a
weapons division there's all sorts of
divisions so this whole deal they have
with john crease of like all right
winner gets to
keep the soul of the valley and the
loser quits karate forever no it's not
so black and white they're different
logistics as there should be when
fighting for the soul of the valley you
know kobrakai one of the things i love
about it is this very
representative of the mindset of los
angeles you would swear everyone in the
world knows about this karate tournament
and this beef going on in reality no one
outside that little bubble gives two
shits i like a couple of the returning
characters too i like that aisha was
back also she's the smart one she was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm gone stingray's
back which i i like stingray i don't
give two shits but again who he is plays
into some really dark angle you know you
see terry silver just beating the living
[ __ ] out of him you're like oh my god he
just
he's [ __ ] stingray up he's basically
like hey i'll let you back into cobra
kai if you say john crease did this to
you but again it's one of those things
terry silver says he's like everyone has
their weakness he's like and you're my
increase and now you gotta go what did
you do john
what did you do oh this must be blowing
your mind here's another mind [ __ ] ralph
macchio's older than me what i like that
the tournament took up two episodes you
know because there was a lot leading up
to it it wasn't just this season it was
many seasons it was a season since the
end of the first season was leading up
to this tournament so i like that they
took two episodes to shine a spotlight
on it and it turns out terry silver paid
off the judge the ref so
it was all [ __ ] miyagi dough should
have won cobra kai did win because you
pay off the right people you can get
away with anything but for this season
that handshake deal they all had you
know john crease was like all right
winner gets the soul of the valley and
gets the franchise and the loser just
stops karate forever it's like what you
think that guy is going to keep his word
i feel like the end of this season as it
was
would have been the end of this season
no matter who won miyagi del wins john
crees is probably gonna be like all
right
i'm still franchising
whatever let's open up more dojos and
daniel larusso would have talked to
chosen and been like will you help me
and chosen was like yep i will
it would have been the ending no matter
who won so i just kind of find that
funny i'm glad chozen's coming back as a
more prominent role because i liked
seeing him in the okinawa scene in
season three just i wanted more i wanted
to see more of him i heard he has a
restaurant in seattle i gotta try it out
i just i gotta i've never eaten there i
wanna go but regardless cobra kai season
four cobra kai is one of the series it's
just it's reliably entertaining for me i
should find it redundant at some point
but i just don't most of which is
because i love johnny that's the thing
this season did also is i felt like
daniel was kind of pushed more to the
forefront whereas daniel in the first
season was a support character but it
was clearly johnny's show now it's
johnny and daniel's show and i like it
most when it's johnny's show because i
just i love johnny johnny's a flawed
person in a world that basically is
formed to have no place for him in it
but he carved a place for him in it he
made himself fit in this world that's
nothing like him but all in all i dug
season four of cobra kai and i'm gonna
clock into season 5 of cobra kai
probably get you a review a month late
you think mike barnes is going to be one
of the senseis that we're on the cobra
kai locations i mean i don't require
them to bring everybody in but in a
world where they've brought a lot of
people in mike barnes is kind of the
only one left out or at the very least
snake you know it but all right start
the clock begin the countdown for season
five that's kind of how cobra kai is for
me i love it where's the cobra kai
season four have you seen it what did
you think about it how does it compare
to the other seasons of cobra kai rank
your seasons of cobra kai i guess is
exactly what i'm saying but whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you